maya wiley wants to be the next mayor of
new york city replacing bill de blasio
in fact she has been endorsed by
alexandria ocasio-cortez
so you can imagine that maya wiley
believes very strongly in defunding the
police in fact at a recent debate
maya wiley suggested we might disarm the
new york city police department
attorney general tis james is proposing
legislation
to limit cops from firing their weapons
use of force
as a last resort now some might ask why
not go
all the way and take away the guns all
together well look you know one of the
things we have to do
is acknowledge that the mayor's job is
safety
we would take the guns away from them
and that does mean
that we want smart policing i think we
know that we have a problem with illegal
guns coming into this city
but will you take the guns away from the
nypd i
am not prepared to make that decision in
a debate
well you'll be surprised by two things
one she's being funded by george soros
she's under soros shill just like bill
crystal and all the rest of the people
who say things that clearly aren't good
for america why because
soros the second thing you might not be
shocked to learn we learned this from
the daily mail
is that why maya wiley doesn't really
believe in defunding the police how do
we know this because she and her
neighbors pay thousands of dollars every
year for their own
private police to protect their
neighborhood including wiley's
2.75 million dollar home carol markowitz
is a columnist at the new york post
she joins us tonight to assess carol
thanks so much for coming on
it's kind of amazing that someone with a
straight face would
say defund the police take away their
guns and then pay for our own private
police or should we not be shocked
that's right you know i was on your show
last summer and i said the only people
who want to defund the police are rich
people and here we go
maya wiley here to prove it a rich
person who wants to strip poor people of
services
wants to take away their police
department who wants to take away their
gifted education for their kids while
her kids go to gifted education
and obviously she's against school
vouchers even though her kids go to
private school
so she's one of the typical hypocrites
that we have running in new york city
but
maya wiley candidacy is for people who
like the incompetence of the bill de
blasio administration but just don't
think he's quite marxist enough
what's so interesting and honestly
infuriating is that my wiley
is a rich person that's okay i am too
she sends her kids to private school she
has private security and all the rest
but she poses
as a victim how does she get away with
that that's right
well you know friendly media always
helps uh but i think that the real thing
is that a lot of new york liberals are
just like her they are also wealthy they
also want to defund the police and i
guess they have in their minds that they
could always hire private security just
like maya wiley
you know i saw bill de blasio mayor bill
de blasio walking around park slope
yesterday i mean it was middle of the
day and he wasn't at work
but he didn't have security with him so
she's really to his left where
she really is do as i say that as i do
shouldn't there be
really quick some kind of law that
requires the people who make our laws to
live with the consequences of the laws
they make
well that would be nice tucker i'm not
going to count on maya wiley to pass any
laws like that
because i think they would be most
harmful to her
you know if you're into equity and
diversity and inclusion you should not
be allowed to go to aspen or martha's
vineyard
ever you should be living next to
section 8 and i'm dead serious carol
markowitz great person good to see you
tonight thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else